ladies and gentlemen the next city
councilor for the great city of Pawnee
Bobby Newport hi I'm Bobby Newport you
know we're two days into this campaign
and so far it's going great
in fact I don't know why they call it a
campaign because up until now it's been
a camp pleasure all right hey why don't
we line up for autographs and free Bobby
bars how's it going I'm Bobby Newport
but you probably knew that already
well mr. Newport we meet at last I'm
Leslie Knope Oh joke so do you want me
to sign it to miss Lowe or just Nizhny
what no Leslie's fine
Leslie yep miss Knope is a candidate for
City Council been calling your office
tried to set up a debate oh no you guys
are robbed I'm running unopposed I'm
pretty sure I'm running unopposed right
nope
you're not running unopposed you're very
opposed by me Oh terrific
I'll that mean people I love it yeah
what do you guys do we we just told you
we're gonna be running for City Council
right here have a Bobby bar oh I have my
dad made him okay folks hey I'm Bobby
Newport I think we scared him hey I'm
Bobby Newport I'm a regular guy I like
dogs
I'm here with my Persian Greyhound
raclette it was given to me by my buddy
the Pretender to the crown of all saw
slur n hi I'm Bobby Newport
my dad is friends with John Cougar
Mellencamp that's pretty cool we're not
gonna quit the campaign why would we do
that
because I want it come on give me it
give me it give me it
come on gimme it just give me the
election I'm sorry please please well
Leslie he does make a compelling
argument come on Bobby
oh it's not patty can I ask you a
question why are you even running for
office you know what I need some
to do to get my dad off my back that
seemed easy what about you are you doing
it is your dad I'm running for office
because I want to improve the lives of
the people that I love in the city
that's the greatest city in the world
wait what does that even mean
hey I've got an idea how about you quit
running then I win but then I let you do
all the work I'm not going anywhere and
we are gonna debate soon and I need to
warn you I know my stuff so you should
toughen up why are you guys smiling I
feel bad
hey quick question that little girl from
your video oh my god she's so cute do
you think you could talk to her and let
her do an ad for me that girl is me as a
10 year old how'd you do that
I believe that I've earned your vote
Bobby Newport believes he can buy it and
maybe that's because he's never earned
anything his entire life dennah hurt my
feelings
hurt my feelings you're supposed to be
this positive person can't we just talk
about things we like well so just a
reminder to our candidates to keep it
civil looking at you Leslie ah that's
okay Joan I'm okay I'm just I'm nervous
and I'm nervous
okay I guess I want to do a good job
because I like when people think I do a
good job and I want your vote because I
want Pawnee and my dad to see what I'm
made of so let's do this
[Applause]
two guys in Jersey this question about
public safety comes from Twitter because
apparently that's something that happens
now at munch meat 2015 asks pani used to
be safe someone stole my car what will
you do to make Pawnee safe and can you
help me find my car I guess I would like
to tell mr. münch mate that I think that
stinks that happened to him you know one
time a guy stole some downhill skis out
of my Jeep and I was so mad I punched a
mailbox I'm against crime and I'm not
ashamed to admit it
I'm an American
my father is an American my mother is an
American my godfather is the Viceroy of
the Principality of Liechtenstein Daniel
Craig no Timothy Dalton
I guess my thoughts on abortion are you
know let's just all have a good time for
the record I'd appear in a film with any
of my fellow candidates this last
question before the break is for mr.
Newport some not me have criticized your
involvement with your father's candy
company sweetums what's your affiliation
with big business affect your decisions
as a city councilor I want to run this
town like a business
my opponent Leslie Knope has a very
anti-business agenda recently my dad
told me that if Leslie Knope wins the
election they'll probably have to move
sweetums to Mexico
that would be terrible of course
thousands of people in this town would
lose their jobs and we all wouldn't have
candy now I'm not saying that it's gonna
happen but I do know this if I win I bet
I could get them to stay how do we fix
this town I have no idea you tell me
that's what I'm counting on you telling
me this is my home
you are my family and I promise you I'm
not going anywhere
holy let's see that was awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
it was alive we'll talk about it well we
did it we did it oh my god I was so
nervous but we completely got through it
I felt this good since I scored that
lacrosse goal at state seriously hey
party in my dad's lake house bring
wherever you want
hey Bobby oh hi
well Playboy why don't you play with the
real one oh I like this one better
little guy looks like me you know my mom
was a great athlete when she was a kid
so in junior high I joined the track
team to impress her even though I hated
it and at the end of the year I ran the
5000 meters in this huge track event and
I finished dead last I thought she was
gonna be really disappointed in me but
she wasn't she ran up to me and she
wrapped me up in this big hug and she
told me she had never been more proud of
me
thanks Leslie that's a great story I'm
not her censuring at the point you
finished this race Bobby the campaign is
over and you finished winner loose I bet
you anything that your dad was proud of
you now I get it
here you go your mom and my dad are both
dicks a lot of people have been asking
me how I feel about everything that's
happened today
well let me tell you a little story my
dad was this amazing athlete when he was
a kid when I was in junior high I
started doing track just to impress him
even though I hated it at the end of the
year I entered the 5000 meters and I won
it was awesome
my dad wrapped me in a big hug said he
was proud of me that's just a great
story that happened between
we're dead that's my story before I go I
want to bring up a special guest
somebody who's been very supportive and
mega-cool today Leslie Knope will you
come up here what come on come up here
you know Leslie's been getting a lot of
heat today
but I want you all to know that we
talked person-to-person and she's really
great people should stop being so mean
or in fact if you don't vote for me
tomorrow you should vote for her because
she's super super awesome lady Leslie we
did it yeah
maybe we're not that the reason why
Bobby and I are appearing together is to
send the message that everyone should
get out and vote no matter who they're
voting for it that's right another
awesome point by Leslie that's why I'm
voting for you that's so funny you're
laughing at your joke what joke I am
voting for you you're not voting for
yourself
Leslie you camp over yourself I don't
think pretty sure that's illegal
what is that don't touch it
let's see I can't figure this thing out
can you help me yeah just hang on a
second Bobby ink all over my hands and a
pen thing you came off the chain
you